prouvez dis nous ce que tu vas être où
est le fond tu viens de le toucher ou la
mangue du bien de l'épouser en nous
basant mais des scellés moi nous nous
pas jean baisser les bras d'eau ma peau
mate shoah que ce bois
la copa jackson bois et tout page en
bbcd braquo dopage a fait baisser les
bras d'eau la pompe à chew accueillera
la compagnie a toutefois baissé les bras
mais dix ans il a combattu aux arrêts et
lehmann resistance in a coma tuyaux va
baisser les bras résistance et notre
match au service et les moins résistants
6 928 à meriem mois l'italie le
collectif hip hop
nomadic massive qui est en tournée
européenne devrait très bientôt un an
quelques jours à peine ils se rendent en
france ils sont connus pratiquement sur
les cinq continents
il chante comme si c'était cinq
continents et ils sont un peu plus
nombreux lacets la version la mini
version de nomadic massive avec nous ils
seront avec nous encore pour deux autres
chansons travers cette émission spéciale
qui est préparé par radio canada
international j'ai des collègues ici on
va vous les présenter et également avec
le soutien technique remarquable
logistique
en plus de ça de radio canada ils sont
ici tout ordre venu alors merci beaucoup
d'être venu à cette émission spéciale
dont le thème est l'inclusion et vous
êtes ici nombreux mais est encore plus
nombreux sur le web cette émission est
d'abord une émission web télé qui est
transmise en direct sur les plates
formes traditionnelles de radio canada
international sur facebook sur youtube
sur d'autres imaginent aussi qu on ne
mentionnera pas mais également sur you
et serions bien ils ont pointé leurs
caméras si vous voulez sur le site web
ils reprennent le signal se dire que
tous les employés de radio-canada
travers le pays en ce moment
regarde cette émission spéciale sur
l'inclusion en ce mois de l'inclusion
ici à travers la société radio canada
alors je vous présente via beaucoup de
monde ici
sur les différents plateaux on va parler
au groupe nomadic massive un peu plus
tard à l'émission pour parler de leurs
efforts d'inclusion de leur succès
également dans ce cette aventure pour le
moment je vous présente les invités de
radio canada international vous avez wii
ou de la section chinoise de
radio-canada qui apportera des notions
importantes par rapport à sa communauté
comment elle voit son inclusion ici à
radio canada et plusieurs personnalités
ou personnes d'origine chinoise qui
travaillent avec nous et d'autres diront
pas tellement 1
et puis il ya également quelqu'un qui
est un ancien correspondant de guerre je
vais vous décrire comme ça parce que ils
sont peu nombreux dans le monde et ils
font remarquable travail très précieux
les 25 ans de la section anglaise de
radio-canada qui s'y nouent et environ 3
4 ans de façon permanente à temps avant
ça vous étiez un contractuel comme
toujours d'entre nous il ya également
chanté à la liste shenzhen qui est avec
qui tu avec nous
qui pourrait dire c'est pas une ancienne
auditrice de radio canada international
en afrique mais elle aurait pu l'être si
elle avait écouté essayé à l'époque elle
a un jour décidé de quitter le cameroun
elle a travaillé au 15e ronde comme
journaliste elle est venue ici pas
d'abord un art du canada mais elle est
allé d'abord à l'université laval où
elle a appris le journaliste ici et puis
elle va être un point central dans
quelques instants de la discussion
là ça c'est des invités de rci il ya
aussi avec nous évidemment des collègues
que l'on qualifiera de d'invités de
marque pour ne pas dire remarquable on à
michel ici cormier directeur de
l'information de radio canada
international encore pour quelques temps
vous partez au mois de juillet la mi
juillet
jusqu'à une date de fixée oui j'en suis
sûr le 31 juillet très bien appuyé il
est secondé par un compagnon des ondes
qui également va pouvoir parler d'eux
d'aspect très important par rapport à au
développement de la captation de
l'inclusion ici à radio canada c'est à
dire
johanne blouin qui est avec nous bonjour
bonjour juin je vais non va on va en
beaucoup à
les vers vous pour avoir des
statistiques des chiffres des données
très précises qui vont permettre aux
gens de saisir l'évolution des choses et
dans certaines sortent une fois le
manque d'évolution s'étendent aussi qui
vous préoccupe depuis très longtemps
tout à fait tout à fait donc ses
environs cette radio canada dans un rôle
là et avant il ya un comité d'inclusion
et de diversité radio-canada est ce que
vous vous étiez là vous travaillez à ça
avant la création de ce comité avec luc
simard qui en est le directeur
donc le comité existait avant le cam en
moi aussi bon je comprends que ça fait
déjà un bout tant que ça roule
puis aussi une gouvernance qui existent
donc ailleurs également aux simples
alors évidemment j'ai quelqu'un ici une
collègue de travail
je sais pas une collègue leur signaler
travaille pratiquement à côté à côté de
nous vous avez voulu dire qui vous êtes
ce que l'invité mystère c'est la place
d'honneur il ya plusieurs places
d'honneur marqué mais je m'appelle
melissa maulin depuis je travaille avec
mes collègues à l'espace autochtone non
j'ai une chronique d'ailleurs pour
répondre aux questions du public
toutes les questions sont obama a
demandé mais je suis aussi je fais
partie de la wapikoni mobile comme
présidente je suis co fondatrice
pourrait donc no more québec
je suis ambassadrice de conscience 2007
pour amnesty international qui la
fondation david suzuki récemment
responsable des campagnes boréale et
caribou à l'habitude ce qui donc je
jonglais beaucoup de chapeaux mais
toujours avec en tête les premières
nations dont je vous ai réservé le
lancement spécial de cette émission
spéciale
oui mais d'ailleurs je voudrais je tiens
à remercier les prairies et les peuples
qui nous accueillent sur leur territoire
qui nous permet d'avoir une belle
activité en 17 journées donc c'est
toujours bon d avoir en tête qu'on fait
des activités sur des du public
ce qui est bien plus qu'agréable de ce
qui est fondamental depuis longtemps j'y
pense d'avoir une collègue ou un
collègue de la mise en ont toujours
quelqu'un avec moi avec qui on peut
partager quelqu'un qu'on
avec lequel on a beaucoup de respect et
d'amitié je me tourner vers microphone
un peu solitaire comme soir en tout cas
bonjour paloma à la voir se promener
beaucoup parmi vous rassurez vous mais
de ce côté là où on a des invités
spéciaux les invités qui travaille à
radio canada et qui vont illustrer les
hauts et les bas de la diversité il se
défie de l'inclusion à radio-canada
paloma willy même vous avez du chapeau
non seulement vous êtes co animatrice
mais elle est aujourd'hui nous parle
évidemment du coeur j'imagine mais aussi
de la raison vous vous travaillez au
comité ont fait mieux comme unité dont
on parlait un peu plus tôt sur
l'inclusion et la diversité et vous vous
donnez de la formation en fait je suis
formatrice jouit auprès des journalistes
journalistes à la recherche pour des
radio canada en ce qui concerne
l'inclusion et l'équité à radio-canada
donc on leur parle de plusieurs manières
des douves rénos horizons et des
présenter de nouveau s'inviter dé
prendre des risques en ce qui concerne
la diversité à radio canada surtout au
niveau des signes de s'inviter au nom de
wii parlez nous de vos invités vous avez
jeunes en quelques secondes je parle
beaucoup je parle beaucoup pour vous
permet d'y aller oui je vais y aller
tout de suite donc on a ici j françois
qui est chef de la planification à la
grille programmation aussi bon jeu
jennings
je vais là mais on a aussi des dragons
salle est ce qu'on connaît tous parce
que l on entend sa voix souvent d'alès
information radio et les journalistes
des bons jours diana internautes basso
qui est agente formation médias
numériques bonjour à carlos on a aussi
pascal pascal laby chef de développement
applications instigateur du forum voix
lgbt qu plus de radio-canada bonjour
pascal et puis pauline pénicaud qui est
adjointe à la réalisati à la réalisation
à la radio bonjour pauline ça va bien
donc moi ce qui est ce qu'il ya des
feedbacks je veux juste savoir ce que
c'est réglé parfait donc pour continuer
à impressionne pas nocivité ce n'est pas
noir je voulais vous faire une petite
une petite parenthèse ici parce que
j'aimerais savoir quelles sont les
attentes de nos ses invités concernant
cette émission parce qu'il commençait
ont pas beaucoup de diversité beaucoup
d'impulsion
mais au jeu murray savoir qu'est ce
qu'est ce que ça vous vient les ce
qu'est ce qui vous vient à l'esprit
quand vous pensez à la diversité et
l'inclusion pascal moi je trouve que
c'est une très belle première étape pas
juste cette émission mais le mois de
l'inclusion radio-canada nationale dans
l'inclusion comme si c'est une première
étape
ça doit être suivi des engagements
concrets mais je trouve que c'est une
très belle première étape de poids être
ici en discuter tous ensemble voir ce
qu'on peut améliorer comment améliorer
les choses parce qu'il ya toujours place
à amélioration
donc très confiant pour l'avenir pour
moi c'est très positif comme comme
première étape
pauline peut-être les gens se posent la
question pourquoi vous inviter à
participer à cette émission de la paix
l'inclusion et radio-canada d'autres
nous un peu votre le contexte dans
lequel vous êtes invités alors déjà je
pense que c'est très important de faire
ces actions comme ceux ci est d'inviter
vraiment des personnes dans différents
milieux différentes cultures et de
rassembler les gens justement par
rapport à ça que ce soit par rapport au
handicap mais aussi au sexe à personne
donc je te prie ceux présents pour
contraire des accents
et vos sapins par rapport à cette
émission particulier c'est vraiment de
ça de continuer d'informer les gens
d'amener cette confiance pour que les
gens puissent se sentir à l'aise d'en
parler justement parce que dès qu'il
avait confiance on peut en parler et on
peut trouver plus d'action pas la même
question donc d'une françois quelles
sont vos attentes mais attend que ça
fait 18 ans que je travaille à radio
canada et c'est la première fois en 18
ans qu'on a une initiative de la sorte
donc on en parle et je trouve ça très
bien donc les gens sont sensibilisés
donc il va avoir un apport des gens des
surtout des minorités visibles des gens
que d'autres cultures parce que de plus
en plus montréal canada sont le québec
on devient multiculturelle donc il ya
beaucoup d'immigrants donc arriver vers
20 30 23% de la population va dé la
minorité visez donc il faut en parler
c'est une bonne chose
et surtout il faut mettre des choses en
place c'est pas juste en parler je vais
parler c'est bien mais il faut mettre
des choses concrètes comme qu'il a dit m
enfin en ce qui concerne la diversité on
sait que 50 % de la population
montréalaise à au moins un parent né à
l'étranger donc c'est pour ça qu'on en
parle maintenant c'est le temps je crois
donc jean-françois ça fait 18 ans qui
travaillait si diana gonzalez a fait
moins de temps que travaille à radio
canada dans quelles sont vos attentes
par rapport à cette émission
mais c'est surtout donc de donner une
vitrine mais cette diversité parce
qu'elle existe on est là et aussi savoir
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour qu'il y
ait davantage de diversité à
radio-canada également donc là vous
voudrez pour tenter d'être aussi la
diversité d'accent vous entend à la
radio
exactement c'est peut-être une diversité
qui existe qu'on voit radio canada mais
qu'on n'entend pas souvent
donc c'est l'occasion de l'entendre
voilà et coin carlo vous travailler ici
depuis si longtemps aussi mais vous êtes
aussi partie du comité du forum voix
lgbt qu plus de radio canada qui est une
initiative qu'a commencé avec pascal
entre autres donc et vous par rapport à
cette émission qu'est ce que vous
attendez
mais en effet pour moi c'est une belle
initiative
ça veut dire je me sens privilégié de
l'effet dé pouvoir participer dans deux
comités
donc je trouve quelque chose que c'est
très important c'est l'effet des quais
on lance la discussion ici et c'est une
façon de sensibiliser à tout le monde
mais le plus important pour moi c'est
que nous on lance quelque chose de grand
ici mais on va faire que tout le monde
ici qu'ils écoutent ça par la suite il
va y aller à son bureau il va discuter
avec son collègue qui va aussi discuter
donc on lance la boule de neige qui va
faire plus grand par rapport à ça puis
tu parlais tout à l'heure avec diana par
rapport à la diversité des cinq sens
c'est très important parce que moi j'ai
la chance de me promener pour donner des
formations des manques tombe jusqu'à
vancouver
et oui il ya la diversité celle qu'elle
visible mais aussi on a des communautés
que radio canada et représente la
communauté franco manitobain la
communauté française quoi la communauté
acadia ces gens là que c'est des
francophones minoritaires
il veut aussi primés 10 à moi il veut
aussi s'entendre à l'antenne de radio
canada stephen je vous souhaite la
parole j'ai fait un gros tour merci
beaucoup de m'avoir laissé souffler un
peu que j'ai écouté j'ai samassa me
donne de l'énergie encore plus j'en
avais beaucoup mais là ça va mieux
encore mieux écouter voici ce que je
fais normalement lorsque je fais une
émission nous c'est le vendredi on fait
une mission web télé on est habitué à
faire sans faire n'importe quoi alors le
vendredi on fait du monsieur qui
s'appelle tam-tam canada et on pose
trois questions aux invités et
généralement c'est des collègues tout
aussi ignorant que moi même sur la
réalité canadienne on essaie de faire
comprendre le canada aux autres
aujourd'hui on a essayé de faire
comprendre la diversité et l'inclusion
au zoo d'accord on va faire ça avec les
gens qui sont assis qui mangent avec
nous qu'ils prennent le café et qui nous
observent d'accord alors je j'ai trois
questions chaque question on ajoute des
points à la fin des missions si vous
avez 100% tant mieux pour vous on va
essayer de faire gagner le nom maximum
possible de personnes d'accord on n'est
pas très sévère aujourd'hui vous je pose
une question de prendre la question
on va appeler remue méninges pour le
plaisir et qui porte pour 20 points
d'accord donc si vous ratez c'est pas
grave vous pouvez ou racheter plus tard
sa porte sur 100 points au total notre
affaire bon voici la question en 2011
la présence des journalistes appartenant
à des minorités visibles dans les
principaux médias au québec qu'on
finisse par radio canada uniquement mais
dans les principaux médias au québec
radio télé télévision tournait autour de
quel pourcentage environ
alors on va demander à nos spécialistes
de l'inclusion 1
on va commencer par voie qui veut
commencer lever la main quel pourcentage
des journalistes des minorités 10% à
tout hasard
j'irai au tour de 10% à 25
je pensais pas au taux de 5% la même
réponse
cinq ans en moi aussi 5% alors nous on
cherche si vous êtes un peu à 5% plus ou
moins la bonne réponse on vous accorde
accord n'y a pas de problème on va se
tourner vers les autres lever la main si
vous voulez participer
si vous pensez que c'est 25% voler dans
les réponses données lever la main pas
une main une seule non je pense qu'ils
en parlent avec une collègue on va
essayer 50% à en-tête d'une réponse cinq
ans pour ça non 5 % oui c'est la bonne
réponse accordez-vous 20 points tant
mieux merci tous ceux qui ont 10 5%
avait à vous savez tous 5.20 points
pendant
voilà pour les autres on a bien sûr il y
aura d'autres jeux alors ça c'est ce qui
ressort d'une enquête faite en 2011
il y avait aussi une enquête faite en
2000 par florian sauvageau que tout le
monde à limite je connais tu arrivé à la
même conclusion 97% des journalistes
étaient blancs c'est ça à l'époque
aujourd'hui je pas si on disait la même
chose dans les mêmes termes on aurait
peut-être d'autres mots d'autres termes
pour d'expliquer la réalité en tout cas
c'est ce qui se passait à cette époque
là je me tourne vers mme alice jean
d'esme ma collègue de travail section
française de radio-canada international
avant que le jeu se joignent à nous elle
était à l'université laval
après être arrivé du cameroun magnifique
pays bilingue français anglais
merci pour magnifique pays effectivement
moi c'est alice chantal john dube je
viens du cameroun où j'ai travaillé
notamment à la télévision nationale
comme journaliste
donc une fois arrivé ici
et au canada et notamment ici au québec
je suis allé à l'université laval dans
le cadre de ma maîtrise en communication
publique et c'est dans ce cadre là que
j'ai effectué ma recherche sur la
représentation des journalistes issus
des minorités visibles dans les médias
le cas de sibiti et de radio canada
en quelle année ça là ça se passait en
2012 c'est en 2012 que j'ai présentées
cet essai là et donc il était question
d'analyser les bulletins d'information
les éditions de 22 heures aussi bien en
anglais qu'en français à la télévision à
la télévision oui contrairement à
florian sauvageau qui avait étudié les
journaux nationaux de façon générale la
radio la télévision la presse écrite
moi j'ai travaillé notamment sur la télé
et j'ai voulu donc analyser les éditions
de 22 heures
parce que j'ai estimé que ce sont les
éditions représentative de l'ensemble
des nouvelles nationales du pays et donc
ayant observé donc ses bulletins de
nouvelles sur deux mois je suis arrivé à
trois principales conclusions
la première c'est que enfin c'est une
conclusion qui peut vous paraître
abyssal mais totalement abject
mais c'est le reflet de la réalité donc
en 2011
les journalistes de minorité visible à
l'antenne de radio canada représente 2%
de l'ensemble
donc c'est pas très très loin du constat
des faits florian sauvageau en son temps
nous an plus tôt douze ans plus tôt il
était arrivé à cette même conclusion là
mais là il avait analysé l'ensemble des
médias la radio la télé la presse écrite
et ils avaient constaté que moi que la
représentation était très très blanche
alors à siby si le tableau avec quelque
peu évolué parce que nous avions 13 %
des minorités visibles
un chiffre qui était davantage proche de
la présence du taux de présence des
minorités visibles au sein de la
population canadienne
on parle d'un taux de 10 9% dont entre
19 et 13 % nous voyons que le fossé
- élargi qu'entre 2 et 10 9%
donc je suis arrivé à la conclusion que
les minorités visibles sont sous
représentés à l'antenne de radio-canada
et de chibi 6 mai avec une nette
amélioration sur une période de 12 ans
pour cible ici donc voilà alice
fantastique exposé un piège avez une
maîtrise du métro micro là qui montre
votre passé à la télévision s'est fait
assez bien pas de merci ça c'est
évidemment dans notre machine à remonter
le temps c'est à longtemps il ya six ans
ben oui ces choses ont certainement
évolué depuis
on l'espère et on le souhaite vivement
et c'est pour ça qu'on se tourne vers
nos estimés collègues
on les appelle les invités de marque
alors on les rappelle johan swahn
drouhin et michel cormier bonjour un
nouveau jour alors vous êtes là comme
des compagnons parce que vous allez
aider l'un et l'autre faire la preuve
que les choses bougent
alors qu'est ce combat oui il faut je
pense que ça bouge
ouais bon allez je pense que je peux
dire que les choses changent est ce que
ça change de s'éviter toujours la
question donc spécifiquement
radio-canada ce qu'on remarque qu'au
cours des cinq dernières années une
effectivement l'augmentation et environ
6 % des employés de radio-canada donc
seulement service français
qui sont ils soumis à utiliser c'est ce
qu'on voit au dernier au 1er avril
dernier pour une site de 10% si on se
donne à fond pourquoi la cible est à 10%
et non pas à 19hoo à 23 qu'on verrait
par exemple géant et métropolitaine de
montréal c'est tout simplement parce que
nos rôles son héros constamment médias
et donc les prix de la main d'oeuvre
dans ces rôles est d'environ cercle on
parle il ya un certain niveau
d'éducation qu'il faut atteindre un
certain john landau langage également
pour travailler au sein d'une entreprise
de communication qui est différent par
exemple que pour un autre poste il ya un
rayon c'est ça qu'on déterminante il ya
un bassin de 22% des migrants mais en
réalité on peut pas atteindre ce
pourcentage dans notre dans notre
personnel c'est ça c'est effectivement
pense qu'on peut dire c'est que le
bassin qu'on a et plus précis que la
population en général donc on est
capable de savoir exactement
donc quel type de poste les gens
occupent dans quelle bassesse qu'on peut
recruter des candidats l'externe baie
james et nuances là parce que vous me
l'avez appris comme ça au téléphone
lorsque vous ai parlé parce qu'on
dépasse la manchette du journal qui dit
seulement 2 % de gens qui travaillent
dans les heures qui viennent des
minorités n'est ce pas tout à fait n'est
pas monsieur cormier
vous êtes un spécialiste des manchettes
évidemment il faut aller derrière la
manche est oui et écouter les certains
et en rattrapage énorme affaire on est
tentant de le faire non seulement pour
les journalistes mais aussi pour lui
tout tout tout la population qu'on évite
sur nos tribunaux si pour diversifier
les points de vue aussi alors c'est
d'autant plus important que par exemple
ça affecte un pull ce qu'on produit
si je prends par exemple la question de
plan d'action de l'immigration de
l'intégration de migration tu es
vraiment maintenant qu'ils qui dominent
l'actualité depuis deux ans à peu près
si on a des gens qui ont vécu ces
expériences qui peuvent comme
journaliste en témoigner y couvrir le
regard est beaucoup plus riche et si ce
sont des gens qui n'ont pas vécu ces
événements
donc c'est donner un exemple de quel
point à quel point c'est plus riches
comme couverture lorsqu'on a des gens
qui ont cette expérience ce qu'on est en
train de faire par exemple informations
on a vu aussi il y avait des blocages
les obstacles pour des gens issus de la
diversité qui n'était peut-être pas
aussi important que pouvaient le reste
de la population qui n'est ici alors par
exemple sur la question du du français
les tests de français ont les seins
refaits pour qu'il soit pas un blocage
parce que c'est pas vrai que tout le
monde décrit instinctivement comme on
apprend à écrire ici ou un peu dans la
société québécoise ou canadienne
française
alors donc on a fait des tests de
français qui sont sont pas des
repoussoirs pour les gens ça ça nous
aide beaucoup
nous aimons c'est qu'on fait aussi la
même chose pour les connaissances
générales connaissance générale parce
qu'on peut pas s'attendre à ce que tout
le monde ait les mêmes connaissances non
plus et parfois c'est peut-être pas non
plus un avantage nécessairement et la
troisième chose qu'on fait aussi c'est
qu'on recrute
on l'a changé de mode de recrutement on
vend maintenant dans les facultés
activement pas seulement les facultés
journalisme et met tout toutes les
facultés et on voit dans les foires
aussi d'emploi d'immigration de
diversité pour s'assurer qu'on un point
de contact autres ce qu'on fait
auparavant
parce que ce dont on se rend compte
c'est comme
ça fait longtemps que les gens se voient
pas à notre antenne
ils n'aspirent pas et peuvent pas
aspirer à ces carrière a commenté ce
qu'on brise ce cycle là c'est pour ça
que maintenant on est allé à la
rencontre au devant de plus de 600
étudiants universitaires cette année
c'est la première fois que vous façonne
les avis d'ici on va les voir dans les
facultés et on invite tout le monde
ce sont des gens en philo en ingénierie
en médecine et dentisterie pboc tout le
monde qui est intéressant parce que ça
peut faire des carrières intéressantes
donc c'est ça qu'on a fait et pour
parler un peu de chiffres quand même bon
à l'information maintenant on est monté
à 8% de c'est pas suffisant mais aux
choses aussi c'est que pour chaque
nouvelle embauche je crois pour chaque
quatre nouvelles embauches
il y en a une qui est tenue d'eve de la
diversité donc ça devrait aussi
améliorer les choses mais il faut se
fixer des balises sinon on n'y arrive
pas qu avec des attentions
là vous avez présenté ça de façon
extrêmement diplomatique tenus d'être de
la diversité quand j'étais petit
j'écoutais les émissions à la télévision
américaine en gare ont parlé de la
question des quotas souvenez de ça ça
avait divisé la population énormément
comment ce qu'on on jongle avec cette
notion là pour ne pas froisser campus
rendre ça plus sympathique où je sais
pas on s'entend que c'est à compétences
essentielles ou attendus pour le boss
ont fait pas qu'on vaut mille noms ont
fait pas dans fais pas de faveur à
personne de les mettre dans des poches
les propos des réformes et non plus
c'est pas on n'est pas là dedans mais il
ya moi je sais qu'il ya assez de gens
talentueux de tous les milieux pour
qu'on puisse qu'on puisse remplir ces
sites bull a atteint si ces deux là sans
faire de compromis sur la qualité
la question ne se pose même pas et déjà
excessivement talentueux à l'extérieur
il s'agit des trouver et les intéressés
à venir chez nous vous avez parlé de 8%
dans nos salles de nouvelles
présentement il ya luxe marque voudrait
le faire intervenir en vacances alors
faudrait façon artificielle il faut
l'injecter dans la décontraction il a
fait une entrevue avec la presse le
quotidien la presse qui n'est pas que
lui lui de tenir des statistiques par
rapport combien de personnes se font
partie de la diversité radio-canada lit
parce que c'est la loi de la diffusion
nous on est obligé de faire ça c'est un
contrat qu'on a avec le gouvernement il
dit sa citation ici que j'ai reprise
c'est on est assez loin de notre
objectif pour l'ensemble de la boîte une
entrevue accordée en décembre dernier
c'est mieux en informations ou les
minorités visibles représente 8 5 29% de
l'ensemble du personnel et l'objectif
c'est atteindre 7,9 pour ça donc je joue
là vous me confirmer c'est à pincer de
la nouvelle on a dépassé 2.1 pour ça on
va partage avec ça il ya dessous une
équipe qui est sur place oui bon parfait
ça vaut bien une autre affaire et clé
ça c'est pour ces pour les services
d'information mais il devance une grosse
société il ya plus que ça il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent à
soutenir notre travail et qui font pas
partie officiellement du secteur de
l'information comment ça se passe
présentement je vends au niveau 2 des
attitudes qu'on doit changer on a parlé
ici avec michel qu'il fallait changer
les tests de français les questions
qu'on pose gérer la france toujours le
défi le défi c'est qu'on a un historique
donc on commence avec des systèmes qui
ont des bras si peut-être à une époque
où est-ce qu'on avait peut-être
certaines façons de penser donc ça doit
évoluer avec le temps
donc ce qu'on remarque on vous la
société c'est qu'une grosse partie du
travail de l'éducation
donc vous avez probablement vu que on a
fait des formations sur les prix j
inconscient au cours des deux dernières
années donc ça c'est c'est vraiment des
foyers on ne voudra du canada dans la
dernière année qui ont été d'ailleurs
adapté spécifiquement pour radio canada
avec plusieurs que les courageux qui ont
d'ailleurs fait partie des vidéos qui
ont été créés pour les formations mais
ça c'est seulement les veilles donc ce
qu'on essaie d'enfoncer que les sites
que c'est qu'on devienne plus exposé je
dirais ce qu'on connaît pas qu'on n'ait
pas peur dans le fond d'un confortable
parce qu'une grosse part d'un
confortable là dedans c'est correct
ce qu'on remarque c'est que dans les
autres parties de la boîte donc si on
pense puisqu'il met à siby c'est donc
une réalité un mât qui leur est propre
et y ont leurs défis aussi que les qui
sont très propres
ce qu'on remarque michel parlé tout à
l'heure de ce que de ce qu'on fait ou
est ce qu'on essaie d'aller parler
d'échanger davantage avec avec
débat des candidats potentiels en fait
utilement ce qu'on vise c'est à l'amour
ou est ce qu'ils se trouvent
puis si on avait utilisé un autre nom
pour déverser en tout cas le talent y
est ici chez moi j'écoute les chicanes
vous êtes ces patrimoines vous endormez
depuis combien de temps vous êtes
chroniqueuse en espèces autochtones
deuxième année ça grossit d'ailleurs
quand j'ai commencé c'était un peu une
recherche justement pour les talents
j'ai des collègues qui j'aurai que je
vois là qui sont des nouveaux talents
qui sont rajoutés puis justement offrir
des formations à des gens qui ont qui
ont ce talent inné à la communication à
faire connaître l'information parce que
c'est vrai qu'on rentre dans des codes
sociaux qui sont totalement différent je
parle en tant que femme autochtone est
une des premières choses que le monde
des soeurs mais toi tu parviens france
est au taquet des communicatrices je dis
oui mais je viens du même milieu c'est
juste qu'elle fallu que des gens qui me
donnent la chance et il l'a emporté des
préjugés invisible possibilité que
j'étais comme ses mails et prêcher
visible c'est tout le sais ton accent
français parce qu'ils étaient diffusés
de l'accent innu ou ton juste même ton
apparence physique quand tu réponds pas
aux codes normatif alors que c'est pas
les mêmes pour nous on n'a pas le même
regard sur les gens mais tu dis qu'en
temps quand j'y pense au début j'aurais
jamais même pensé pouvoir être une
chroniqueuse ou avoir accès à parler en
public parce que y'a rien dans les
médias pioche je remonte à 1990 dans la
crise d'autres qui nous disait qu'on
avait notre place à port ci ont bloqué
des pompes à part si on manifeste dans
les rues puis même là on voyait très peu
le visage des princes en ce moment là et
quelques années plus tard c'est si
francis qui a été un peu la force des
événements le mouvement laquelle je me
suis beaucoup impliqué et beaucoup
d'autres voix se sont impliqués c'était
de diversifier les visages c'est pour ça
qu'on était des co organisateurs des
cofondateurs on voulait avoir plusieurs
visages parce qu'on ne peut pas voir
uniquement un ou deux représentants qui
était constamment dans les médias
les voix sont trop différentes les idées
font trop différente donc en étant dès
qu on peut dire écoute et à plusieurs
autres voix et plusieurs messages où bon
invité deux à la fois et des gens plus
le message est passé plus les premières
nations sont apparues dans les médias et
plus les gens sont mis à chercher
justement pas uniquement le hula
autochtone mais la personne qui avait
l'expérience pour parler du sujet et ça
la force et les gens justement à se
défaire des fois de vouloir la personne
avec l'accent francophone parfait où le
visage parfait et ça lui a permis je te
demande de diversifier les visages et
les messages non je pense que ça l'a
enrichi le menu des médias puis à
l'espace autochtone c'est ce qui est
fantastique et avec d'autres médias qui
ont quand même collaboré avec les
premières nations avant les grands
médias de masse il ya eu une possibilité
d'arriver avec des histoires qui n'était
pas uniquement liées aux aspects
négatifs de notre histoire mais aussi
comme on dit nos maux quelles sont nos
communautés et le premier défi que
j'avais que j'avais donnés c'était à des
journalistes petit minot mais les onze
nations et certain journalisme j'ai vu
au jarret pas trop voulu leur imposer de
me répondre sur le coup mais il ya des
gens qui sont venus me voir l'année
d'après on dit j'ai appris mes onze
nations et les gens ont commencé à
s'informer sur les 52 communauté au
québec et ont commencé à grandir alors
leur réseau de personnes avec qui parler
des premières nations et j'ai pu essayer
d'être connecté des gens sur des sujets
alors que pour moi c'est comme si c'est
elle la personne il faut que tu es un
pack néo les gens les avaient pas en
tête
donc je pense que ça l'a permis de
déboucher de débloquer un entonnoir qui
malheureusement faisait pas beaucoup de
place pour les premières nations malgré
le fait qu on a sept mille ans
d'histoire on peut voir dans les livres
d'histoire que les pages qui nous
concerne sont encore très mince mais
tranquillement
je pense que le livre de l'histoire du
canada commencent à être co écrit et
commence à faire de l'espace pour une
présentation messi encore en progression
puis beaucoup de travail à faire écoutez
quand on parle du coeur on s'exprime
bien je me tourner vers oui parce que
oui vous avez comme plusieurs autres
personnes à radio-canada intentions d'ex
responsabilité extraordinaire vous
devrez bientôt nous quitter pour une
entrevue avec un invité donc on ne peut
pas des commandes et mais on peut
s'adresser à vous pour parler de ces
préjugés inconscient mais il ya d'abord
cette question de l' accent on parle des
avantages
comment vous avez dit ça plutôt en
réunion production parlement vous
parliez des modes et les noms avantages
des groupes qu'on dit mon avantage
alors dans le cas des communautés
asiatiques ils sont à l'écouté de radio
canada international qui vermont rien
par exemple il ya ce pas facile
nécessairement de percer puis devenir
des six travail pourquoi oui mais
d'abord il ya la barrière de la langue
il faut dire que les chinois avec le la
langue chinoise et la langue française
c'est vraiment très très différents ou
coûterait très différent et difficile
pour les québécois d'apprendre le
chinois
c'est aussi difficile pour les chinois
qui apprend le français peu importe
comment comme le temps dont on parle de
tests de français ou test de
connaissances mais quand même rémission
est faite en français il faut quand même
et c'est capable de s'exprimer et tapas
et capable d'être accepté par le public
parce que nous toute façon on fait face
à une publique
il faut avant tout le public accepte peu
importe on met des visages différents
goûts accents différente et ça je crois
que pour moi je considère que je
travaille c'est comme une balle à
l'inclusion
je trouve que je travaille sur un autre
front pour le même combat
c'est à dire que j'essayais avec mon
travail de construire des ponts entre
les îlots culturel ou psychologique de
des gens de ma communauté ou kill kill
qu'ils sortent pour voir comment au
doigt ou bien la société qu'est ce qui
est
qu'est-ce-qui yonne intéressant qu'est
ce qu'on est en droit de penser puis
aussi quand je vois que y
justement la semaine passée j'ai parlé
avec quelqu'un il modique aux légendes
senti que ce sont des paresseux ou vient
quand on parle de 30 des choses
j'aimerais bien que je considère ceci
comme un échec de mon travail j'essaie
de les amener c'est à dire pas les
serments accepté mais au moins sa voix
qu'est ce qu'on pense qu est-ce qu on
qu'est ce qu'on pense et qu'est ce qu'on
est en train de regarder vous parlez est
peut-être un jour je me suis dit ils
vont ils vont s'intéresser à
radio-canada peu importe le le visage ou
le où ils peuvent s'intéresser ou bien
s'exprimer ou communiquer en français ou
en anglais
sa voix est pas un jour où ils vont
s'intéresser il quand on parle d'un
talent c'est vrai il ya des talents qui
se cache
puis ils vont ils vont sortir je
voudrais poursuivre sur la question de
l'accent dans quelques moments peut-être
dans cinq ou six minutes avec vous les
veines il y aura avant une prestation de
notre groupe nomadic massive mais
d'abord parlement je veux un bilan de mi
émission avec nos invités spéciaux je
sens qu'ils pensent parce que c' est
temps de rediriger le tir là parce que
c'est pas fini les missions de la
mission s'étend de décider si on s'en va
dans la bonne direction ou pas jusqu'à
maintenant est ce qu'on a réussi à vous
satisfaire vos attentes par rapport à
cette émission
pascal des discussions très
intéressantes moi j'arrête un
commentaire aussi par rapport à ce que
la personne disais à l'instant vis-à-vis
de l'accent français international qui
est qui est promu chez cib ici radio
canada le problème selon moi c'est que
la société évolue et en concentrant
justement sur cet accent français
international on va mettre selon moi à
dos une partie de la
la société qui se retrouve pas du tout
dans cet accent et qui va trouver
artificielle de devoir écouter des
nouvelles ou oui le bulletin de
nouvelles avec un accent qui leur
parlent pas qui leur correspond pas donc
je trouve que c'est très important de
miser sur cette diversité et de
l'accepter à l'antenne à la radio sur
tous nos médias notamment pour cette cet
aspect de l'accent de la langue parlée
d'accord pas de pauline oui mais moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord c'est vraiment
important de continuer de faire ça et
puis comme ce que tu disais à l'antenne
aussi que ce soit la radio
je trouve que c'est très important
concernant la l'inclusion des personnes
avec un handicap
qu'est ce que vous en pensez du travail
qui se fait à radio-canada et de la
discussion qui a eu en ce moment je
pense que ça serait intéressant note que
ces personnes justement à l'antenne
parce que c'est vrai que on n'en voit
pas assez ça peut il peut y avoir des
préjugés et c'est vraiment important de
d'intégrer tout le monde jean françois
est ce qu'on a ce qu'on avance ce qu'on
vous satisfait dans les conclusions
d'aller lé débat tout à fait ça surtout
quand on parle de chiffres michel a
parlé tout à l'heure de fives de passer
de 5% à 7%
il ya une amélioration je vois une
animation depuis que je suis à radio
canada il ya deux choses que j'aimerais
dire un coq premièrement c j'espère que
le mois de la diversité et de
l'inclusion sera pas juste le mois de
juin ce sera pendant toute l'année donc
si on parlera pas de diversité seulement
juin puis après on recommence l'année
prochaine donc j'aimerais ça continue à
parler de diversité tout à néant tes
collègues payante et gestionnaires tous
à pouvoir la deuxième une question que
j'aimerais poser je sais pas si l'on
abordé
qu'est ce que vous pensez de deux mètres
un quota de mettre un quota par exemple
est-ce qu'on peut dire
radio canada a un quota de 5 % atteindre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de sa femme
michelle a parlé du fait qu'un candidat
sur quatre qui étaient sélectionnés
devait venir d'une communauté s'est pas
il n'a pas utilisé le mot le mot avec le
recul
mais un autre chose ça fait ça fait
presque un an qu'on a cette directive le
maintenant avec l'arrivée de michel
bissonnette avait su de la
vice-présidente alors et de renée claude
ménard aussi qui s'en occupe
assez assidûment merci dont il ya
vraiment une il ya une volonté vraiment
comment s'en est il ya des objectifs qui
doivent être atteints chacun sait déjà
on peut l'appeler comme on veut mais il
ya des quotas ou décider des chiffres il
faut arrêter c'est bon cédric il ya
quand même eu aussi un danger pour faire
attention parce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle aussi vouloir la petite phase
brune alors faut comprendre que c'est il
ya dans la diversité culturelle il ya
aussi un aspect culturel qui est pas
uniquement liée à l'identité ethnique et
que ça aussi ça fait partie de cette
belle diversité là qu'on parle d'une
richesse à radio canada ce qui peut être
apporté de plus et ça je pense que les
gens s'en rendent de plus en plus cons
que c'est pas uniquement question de
rajouter des visages mais de rajouter
aussi la saveur qui vient avec les
cultures et qui des fois au si on me
regarde on n'a aucune idée que je suis
nous met la culture à suis vite j'ai pas
j'ai pas l'air mais j'ai la chance aux
vraies questions si c'est important de
rajouter ça nous nos conversations entre
collègues parce que la diversité c'est
un fait la diversité des points de vue
c'est la diversité des parcours aussi
c'est pas justement ce n'est pas
seulement le visage et poliment visible
et diana on parlait justement de la
diversité d'accent on parle d'un chiffre
de 2 200 enfants sur cinq au canada qui
vivent avec un parent né à l'étranger
donc que ça veut dire que ces enfants là
ont déjà leur est elle prête à des cinq
sens donc j'imagine que notre public à
l'avenir être prêt pour le sac s'en bat
les commentaires que je reçois c'est sûr
que ceux des personnes qui i will salue
la présence d'une diversité en ondes
chez curieuse d'entendre ce qui serait
moins favorable parce que sans doute il
y en a
puis pour ce qui est de cette diversité
là et de l'accent des fois je me demande
si c'est pas plus à l'antenne qu'on a eu
peur que ce que les auditeurs peuvent
penser de la présence accent je me pose
la question des fois un carlos donc on
avait des attentes par rapport à cette
émission à date
vous êtes vous êtes content oui en fait
je suis très content parce que en étant
formateur j'aime aussi apprendre puis
les points de vue par rapport aux
premières nations
je l'a entendu c'est des choses que je
connaissais pas piqué je suis en train
d'apprendre que c'est ça merci en effet
si c'est très bien pour moi parce qu'on
discute de tout genre des diversités
diversité sexuelle diversité visible
mais aussi et les premières nations
moi j'ai appris plein de choses pierre
je suis content quand on s'élance sur
tout jardin diversité dans cette
discussion il est prêt nomi les 14
premières nations
les examens ça fonctionne
écoutez alomar on va aller leur nomadic
ensuite on va revenir avec une question
ou à mettre à l'épreuve les compétences
et les points d chacun gagne ce sera pas
moi oui sinon nomadic massive
[Musique]
si la mode lan giga
la solution
[Musique]
encore
son mot pourquoi nos chronos ces mots le
guen seul à l'ultime moment de nos sites
éléments relatifs à un intérêt chez nous
dès veneno accordera de confortables
souterraine importante au vélo son plein
au canada sous la marque nutella
commodity ami el assidi abonnés de la
ville de messine fournir nos veneta pas
dès lors d'y aller elle est chaussée qui
nous avons l'affectation par une place à
des sentiments aux canaries le mieux des
réplicats local de mécanisation des
rides des obstacles mais ça fait ça pour
de bon
what they have les femmes et sa face à
poitiers
m
[Musique]
c'est à ce moment qu'elle a choisi ya
les bars à fait ça
bon comme on donne rien
le théâtre la musique la lyre chaabi
sept jeux non mardi à genève july web
mais il s'attarde sur le lien pour une
assiette ou des brimades qu'il un salam
aleikum les collectionneurs est arrivée
la délégation mon modem sauvé des
bassines après just beat by words words
mon bon ami jack moubine où la plante
seagate barracuda
car il ajouté
on les applaudit à assinie mafia elle
rien moi l'italie nous on est chanceux
on allonge la durée de l'émission
vous étiez au soleil bien évidemment les
véritables stars de l'émission
aujourd'hui
merci d'être avec nous je vais donner
quelques informations vous concernant
parce que il possible que certaines
personnes ne vous connaissent pas encore
ces temps que créé en 1902 réunis
ensemble 2004 vous êtes 1212 d'accord et
vous étiez au départ les mêmes
vous avez un peu changé au niveau du
gross sa bouge encore là ça fait 14 ans
sur la scène locale est aussi
international
bon alors l'international ça commence en
quelle année pour vous
depuis notre naissance quand même oui
vous est donné à paris notamment son
argentin des réfugiés politiques en
gentil puis voilà on a tous un peu
d'histoire
mais l'histoire en simple en question
nomadic massive s'est construit à cuba
donc le disons que ça la saveur
internationale du groupe a commencé même
au départ où on a commencé à voyager etc
depuis le début de l année on parle de
2004 2004 alors que je pose la question
passe quelque part des québécois vont à
cuba donc c'était peut-être présent au
moment de la création n'est ce pas on
sait pas je vais vous demander vous nous
écoutez part et vous parlez entre
professionnels des médias vous nous
regardez bien sûr à la télévision
j'espère c'est pas vrai dit pas qu est
ce que vous pensez l'initiative je peux
vous poser des questions politiques mais
des questions allez-y vous vous
représentez pour nous l'exemple réussi
de la richesse quand on se retrouve tous
et chacun ont dit on va chanter dans
toutes nos langues communes ensemble au
même moment qui veut y aller qui veut
dire qui veut livrer ses impressions et
ses claques avec nomadic massive
on croit vraiment qu'on présente
montréal et ça veut dire le québec aussi
parce que
c'est ici on s'est formée et c'est tout
à fait normal qu'un existe un groupe
existe où on se présente de différentes
cultures en différentes langues et tout
mais en même temps à l'extérieur du
québec on est rarement à l'intérieur du
québec on est rarement vus comme des
québécois on est rarement vu comme un
groupe d'ici puis c'est frustrant pour
mieux aussi clair mais on travaillera
surtout souligner ce point là parce
qu'on trouve vraiment comme reflet de la
société dans laquelle on vit quand vous
allez à l'extérieur vous allez en france
des années en france bientôt je pense de
la semaine prochaine semaine suivante
mois entre juillet la barbe ont les
migrations qui vient du maroc qui sont
beaucoup plus familier encore que nous
est-ce qu'ils se reconnaissent également
dans la création votre groupe dans
l'identité il y à il ya vraiment jeu
j'essaie de comprendre à travers et en
essayant il ya un courant qui passe
quand même dans le haut niveau la wii
avec les musiciens tout ça c'est ça
notre expérience a été assez positif en
voyageant parce qu'on a l'impression de
représenter tellement de culture que
dépendamment ou en valais culture se
retrouve dans la sonorité est aussi dans
les langues mais je pense généralement
c'est surtout dans l'harmonie et la
symbiose qui se crée de voir que c'est
possible parce que c'est pas parce que
on fait partie d'une certaine culture
qu'on va connecter avec ce qui se passe
musicalement juste parce que ça
représente notre culture je pensais que
ça représente quelque chose qui n'a
jamais été vu qu'il n'a jamais été vécue
mais qui ressemble qui est familier et
donc c'est pour ça que ça c'est
intergénérationnel et interculturel et
en france où il ya beaucoup
d'immigration d'ailleurs des pays
hispanophones des pays arabes aux fins d
paie donc de différentes places qui se
retrouve un petit peu dans ce que nous
on représente aussi donc ça ça marche
aussi bien là-bas finalement merci
beaucoup
super sympa on y retrouve à la fin de
l'émission c'est eux qui vont fermer les
missions comme ils ont ouvert l'émission
je vais me tourner vers ceux qui restent
qui n'avaient pas bon il y en a certains
qui peuvent pas ils doivent aller
travailler leur donnant je ne veux pas
être étendue éternellement radio canada
j'ai pour vous tous qui étaient encore
présents ici j'ai ma deuxième question
remuez vous les ménages l'émission il y
en a trois celles ci comptent pour 30
points lever la main si vous avez gagné
les 20 premiers points
james bond on en a trois dans
l'assistance 0 d'accord voici la
deuxième question tout le monde peut
participer
ne vous gênez pas aussi l'institut pour
la citoyenneté canadienne est un
organisme caritatif national cofondée
par adriana un klaxon ancien gouverneur
général du canada
bien sûr et john race une sorte faut-il
de décrire écrivain grand penseur qui
mariée d'ailleurs avec adrian tracks
alors l'institut vient de mener une
enquête et quelques mois auprès de 64
grandes entreprises privées donc par
radio canada mais privées qui emploient
collectivement 1,2 million de
travailleurs canadiens
c'est beaucoup de monde et on leur
demande et vous quel pourcentage de ces
grandes compagnies canadiennes estime
avoir été capable de transformer en
mesures concrètes d'inclusion leurs
convictions en ce qui concerne la
diversité et l'inclusion
donc on veut mais est ce qu'on peut voir
quel pourcentage pense avoir réussi le
coup je me tourner vers ceux qui veulent
déjà se prononcer de donner un
pourcentage palma vous reprenez le fil
je reprends les fils donc les gagnants
premier la date
donc quel pourcentage penser je parle
12% 12% des entreprises privées
canadiens ont réussi leur pari de la
diversité diamant 20% 20 pour ça j'aime
ce sera ça que je suis un peu pessimiste
je restais dans ma fourchette en 2005
aux deux 5-10 10 pour ça alors c'est
ainsi que je suis un peu plus optimistes
ont été entre 20 25 % d'accord 20% un
quart des saints mais des s'employer
alors ça se promène beaucoup de 2 à 25 %
ici autour de la table fadi vous ne vous
nous donnez votre version de la réalité
ben je vais lancer un chiffre comme ça
15 % 15 % très bien 20 % 20 % pour laval
et puis chantal 17% 17%
je vous dis déjà il ya beaucoup de
gagnants ok 13 pour ça je veux pas me
mettre dans l'embarras vous avez une
réponse 25% à 25 pour sa franchise reste
le chief 16
alors si vous étiez à 5% de la bonne
réponse vous gagnez des 30 points vous
lever la main qui a répondu près de 10%
15% à 5 pour ça pauline bon juan carlos
et fadi donc vous savez tout à 50 points
pauline et la 30 et fadi 30 la bonne
réponse et 10% seulement les entreprises
arrivent à réellement tirer parti de ces
avantages la suite de cette cette
histoire plus ou moins grands succès
vers la fin d'émission pour le moment je
me tourne vers les bonnes secondes et je
tardait je voulais vous parler depuis
longtemps de cette question d'accent ils
en ont débattu du côté des invités
spéciaux
je me sentais bouillonner vous ayez
votre grain de sel à ajouter votre
propre version de la réalité
pourriez vous nous dire ce que vous
pensez des accents décès non avantages
comme les décrit le décrit paloma c'est
ça vient d'une personne qui parle
maintenant tous les quatre langues que
je parle avec un accent alors même ma
langue maternelle
quand je reviens je suis d'origine
arménienne quand je reviens à l'arménie
et déjà mais surtout les chauffeurs de
taxi me reconnaît immédiatement que être
d'or quelqu'un qui a passé à 70 d'ordre
le pays j'ai un accent que je ne sens
pas mais même ma langue maternelle
moi je pense qu'on a deux combats menés
on a un combat ici à l'intérieur de la
boîte où on voit ce combat et ça
progresse mais un combat encore plus
important je pense prennent aux
auditeurs kono les gens qui nous
écoutent ni les gens qui nous regardent
les gens qui nous lie parce que je pense
qu'il faut vraiment à sensibiliser la
public que la réalité
ce qu'on voit dans les rues doit être
reflétée dans le monde danse country et
je trouve malheureusement souvent c'est
un on a peur de prendre cette chance et
dire aux gens à écouter voici une
personne qui parle très bien français ou
anglais mais cette personne va voir un
accent et pour le restant de leur vie
pour moi c'est très important qu'on
essaie de intégrer les gens pas juste
les deuxième troisième génération
d'immigrants qui sont en réalité des
canadiens de souche pour mais aussi les
gens comme moi qui sont arrivés au
canada un peu plus vieux déjà avec
certains expérience de vie et qui auront
les accents français anglais russe pour
le restant de leur vie et c'est quelque
chose que dans mon cas je suis comme
aussi un minorité invisible ou un
minorité audible parce que moi je sais
est nommé oui sinon blanc même si en
revanche il serait considéré noire comme
celle le connais parce que je viens du
caucase mais l'occasion aussi aux yeux
plus un occasion aux yeux bleus mais en
russie c'est un caucasien c'est le nom
le terme c'est de noix alors c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut penser que le
vrai combat c'est pas à l'intérieur de
la boîte
c'est à l'extérieur qu'il faut le mener
je voudrais quand même poursuivre à
l'intérieur de la boîte au revoir parce
que j'aimerais poursuivre avec plein
d'idées il ya pas le même palmarès est
encore avec nous je suis là
jeu passez votre temps à parler aux
invités spéciaux cher alors vous donner
une formation
oui aux journalistes aux journalistes
journalistes à la recherche ou et les
questions consulaires ne sont pas
étrangères à la réalité qui est décrite
dans les cours yap l'occupation à
l'intérieur de radio-canada les
journalistes l'exprima informations ils
ne disent mais probablement que si
l'accent est trop fort ne sera pas la
personne ne sera pas l'inviter ne sera
pas acceptée par l'animateur par les
rédacteurs en chef ou encore par le
public
donc c'est une question qui revient
souvent ce qu'on leur dit à l'ats la
formation intacte est ce que on fait pas
de compromis concernant la qualité du
français
la personne doit être capable de donner
un bon show des connaître le sujet dont
elle va parler mais aussi elle et elle
doit a parlé bien le français ou
l'anglais dans le cadre de nos collègues
a subi 6 mai au lac sanaa veut avoir un
accès navette ne veut pas dire
nécessairement qu'on a qu'on parle pas
bien français
donc effectivement à radio canada on
fera aucun compromis concernant la
qualité du français c'est évident il
faut pas il faut parler bien vous fait
la démonstration que jamais j'aime bien
sa façon de décrire les choses c'est pas
sa langue maternelle c'est l'espagnol et
puis c'est comme parler à une soeur
alors fantastique merci parlement dit
que j'ai palaxa merci d'écouter
je pense qu'on vend on va neuf minutes
l'émission est terminée donc nos
collègues de masse ils vont pouvoir
profiter parce qu'ils ont un autre ils
ont d'autres obligations ils sont très
populaires la france et attend écoutez
je voulais passer à la section que
j'appelle les questions provocantes et
les mots qui dérangent d'accord
est-ce qu'on accumule des points
répondant aux questions non vacances
dont on en fait non le but c'est de
garder nos jeunes et on en profite pour
poser des questions à un représentant de
l'administration non j'exagère bon les
questions peuvent accorder
c'était quelqu'un qui est une question
provocante et si quelqu'un est question
provoque un de ses côtés par rapport à
ce qu'on a discuté
une bombe a lâché quelque chose à dire
non oui pascal rouiller parce qu'elle
est une petite question un peu
provocante moi je viens du département
de technologie évidemment on sait que
c'est un département très
malheureusement masculin hommes blancs
hétérosexuels 40 50 ans qu'est ce qu'on
fait à travers l'entreprise pour briser
un peu ce paradigme et essayer d'ouvrir
par exemple permettre à plus de femmes
d'accéder à des positions de leadership
dans ces dans ces départements avoir
plus moi évidemment j'aime la diversité
sexuelle donc avoir plus de
représentants de la diversité sexuelle
dans des postes de responsabilités
quelles sont les mesures prises
peut-être que je prends je vais prendre
la question donc jo van les personnes
culture donc nautique et de ressources
humaines
ce que je répondrais s'exprimant je
pense que yes mc kee un an je ne vous la
représentation des femmes pour pour
l'équipe et c'est vraiment spécifique au
niveau de la composante et stm donc de
manière générale dans l'organisation je
pense qu'on fait bien ou la
représentation des femmes c'est vrai nos
produits hier chez coup de point de vue
des différentes composantes incluant
radio canada mais pau ouest et m6 qui
est entraîné de fait au moment où on se
parle c'est de mettre sur pied donc un
plan d'action qui va tomber sur la
nouvelle stratégie triennale
d'entreprise pour diversité inclusion
donc son appel le plan sur la diversité
et l'inclusion 2018 2021
est ce qu'on fait pour la première fois
au moins pour les dix dernières années
c'est qu'on va avoir un plan d'action ou
est-ce qu'on va pour mettre l'accent
spécifiquement sur la représentation des
femmes au niveau du stm est donc ce sera
d'ailleurs publiée dès l'automne donc ce
soit public donc ce qu'on a décidé de
faire et on est d'ailleurs la seule la
seule compagnie dont francophones à le
faire au niveau des médias qu'un autre
question provocante
oui interne oui en effet on parle qui
s'agrandissent la diversité au niveau
des radio canada je travaille pour les
secteurs des médias numériques
le web donc c'est sûr que nous c'est il
ya des toutes les origines c'est très
ouvert mais nous on n'est pas les
visages et on n'est pas la voix de radio
canada donc et nous on travaille pour
les web
mais il n'y a pas personne qui nous
voient il ya pas personnes qui écoutent
notre accent c'est ça est ce qu'il ya
quelque chose d concrets que ça va se
faire
pouvoir par exemple je sais qu'il ya une
émission de radio en alberta où c'est
quelqu'un qui est originaire de
l'afrique qui s'adresse aux gens qu'il
ya une émission donc est ce que quelque
chose comme ça ça va pas être un cas
isolé on va voir quelque chose plus de
ses missions on avait des gens avec des
accents ou des jambes avec des émissions
des variétés prêtait peut-être qu'ils
représentent la diversité
je veux je peux parler de l'information
je voudrais pas parler de des autres
secteurs
ici il est certain qu à mesure qu'on
recrute davantage qu'on a davantage
aussi de jeunes journalistes commencent
dans la boîte ces gens là vont devenir
animateur et c'était ça aussi un petit
peu plus le problème qu'on avait c'est
pour ça que dans lequel évidemment de
l'espace de tonnes avec mélissa on a pu
directement de mettre dans un poste
d'animation et chez moi et ce genre de
ce genre de projet là par exemple nous
permet de six ont vu contourner des des
procédures qui sont peut-être un peu
plus tôt d'ailleurs qu'à deux radeaux si
les jeunes jeune laboratoire de
journalisme aussi qu'ils sont en train
de réinventer le taux de diversité est
beaucoup plus large à tous les points de
vue et on voit que ça vraiment la
richesse du regard qu'il porte sur des
enjeux de société sont très très
rafraîchissante pour ce concert un du
canada alors donc il ya aussi cette
façon là dessus en vue de de promouvoir
des gens les visages si on veut il y
voit pour les mettre à l'antenne alors
cdc décédé début mais ce soit les voit
maintenant qui s'offrent à nous et
l'ambition est là en informations la
première femme qui va me remplacer le
directeur général de la formation
c'est fantastique il ya beaucoup de
femmes qui sont cadres à l'information
alors c'est maintenant il faut s'assurer
que toute la diversité dont se retrouve
aussi dans les postes de décision
stefania question ici sur les mêmes
elles allient rédacteur en chef de radio
canada international il est là peut
cacher ici chez nous alors moi j'ai une
question pour toi stéphane
toi le québécois de souche d'un même
située à peu près aussi bronzé que moi
comment tu te sens et comment tu vis la
diversité autour de toi moi c'est très
facile moi j'ai reçu un appel il ya
vingt ans pour travailler à radio canada
international j'étais à windsor en
ontario il ya un gars qui s'appelle
aussi nous c'est nous qui diop qui
m'appelle dit on cherche quelqu'un qui
se débrouille qui est capable de tout
faire bon et puis radio canada tandis
qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais ce que
je savais c'est que il y avait plusieurs
angles et je savais aussi que moi je
n'ai de mon contexte culturel était
totalement différent du québécois
ordinaire j'avais deux ans je suis parti
pour l'afrique survenu à 12 ans au
québec
tout ce que je connaissais du québec ces
maisons que mes tantes et l'hiver le
froid ou et des fois l'automne les
feuilles c'était bien autrement c'était
l'afrique c'était la couleur les
senteurs
j'ai habité au sénégal j'habitais au
gabon j'ai visité le cameroun
j'ai vécu madagascar j'ai fait plusieurs
pays et j'en suis revenue avec la
conviction que l'afrique c'était la vie
pour moi et j'essaie de partager ça avec
mes petits copains à l'école j'étais au
lycée français à montréal parce que
c'était difficile de m'intégrer au
québec scolairement j'étais jeu système
métrique tous sains et j'essaie de paria
de l'afrique de la vie l'amour europe
soit personne est intéressée
donc moi l'exclusion gelé senti au
méchamment mais c'est il ya deux formes
d'exclusion celui qui dit face à face
moi je peut intéresser et à celui qui
dieu tu parles de quoi c'est ça il ya
deux formes
l'autre forme celle qui dit que t'es pas
intéressé moi mon amour est en alberta
c'est là je me suis marié et puis en
alberta un francophone un gars qui vient
du québec ça se défend mal et il ya des
gens qui vous disent ouais pourquoi est
ce qu'il ya des français sur les boîtes
de céréales ou faisaient des condés des
imbéciles bon ça part de là et puis
aussi quand j'étais en alberta moi j'ai
fait tous en amérindien et ouais
l'alberta se ressemble à personne moi je
me disais sur 100 ma mère mes 40 ans
plus jeune parce que vous allez de même
très bas mais là elle une demie enfin
la bourde sans mon père aussi de son
côté bon je m'étais jamais vraiment
intéressé à ça sauf qu'une fois arrivé
en alberta les regards étaient
différents moi je ressemble à tout le
monde ici au québec là bas on est on est
fondamentalement différent défoncé ils
sont plus blanc là bas quand ils sont
blancs plus blond aussie alors moi c'est
ça l'exclusion
j'ai pas besoin de le crier parce que je
suis capable de je me défends je vis
avec mémé différence je suis très
créatif c'est ça ma grande différence au
final
tant mieux j'ai jamais échoué mais pour
moi avoir des collègues de couleurs
complètement différent d'avoir des
collègues c'est parfait c'est mon
univers et moi pendant des années le
plus grand plaisir de ma vie kim a été
enlevé il ya quelques années lorsqu'on a
perdu certains outils au financement et
que j'étais radio-canada donation il
faut dire moi je faisais une émission
extraordinaire qui est en rapport avec
les auditeurs à travers le monde
je leur explique quel canada et à
travers ça je connais mieux comprendre
comment expliquer les différences du
québec durance du canada j'ai vécu dans
ces du monde là qu'on parle de deux
solitudes mais en fait vous vous
ressemblez pas mal tout le monde
moi j'ai vécu je vois les choses avec
beaucoup de relief
c'est ça mon avantage le relief
autochtone c'est ça pour ça j'aurais pu
enquêter davantage sur les antécédents
mes racines autochtones
on ne faisait pas dans ma famille
c'était pas bien mais c'est des choses
qu'on doit faire on doit tous allés en
soi pour certains qu'on vend un combat
individuel c'est pas nécessairement un
combat de groupes mondiaux il faut que
ce soit des noms des chiffres des
pourcentages
oui mais moi là dedans comment je me
défends comment j'avance beaucoup de
gens qui sont ici je le sais 10
ceci bien essayé puis ça mais aux
personnes pensent à ceux ci personnes
pensent à se lasser des choses pour eux
alors je moi ce que j'aime bien c'est
que chez nous à radio canada
international
j'ai pas besoin de faire des dessins
pour dire les gens pourraient quand même
faire plus d'efforts tout le monde est
conscient de ça alors j'ai un beau
milieu de times jugeant ce jeu faut pas
me poser des questions motion et c'est
je suis connue faut jamais posé de
questions je n'arrête pas de parler mais
là j'ai dit ce que je pensais
alors merci je vais terminer sur les
crédits d'émission parce qu'il va
falloir le laisser à quitter donc
écouter vous chantez après ça on donne
les crédits d'émission une dernière
prestation de nomadic massive d'accords
[Musique]
d
mika ayo
[Musique]
à l'angle
tiens encore au maroc à to'ata minium et
pozo tout un bon femme sauter confie des
missions traîne ses chais 516
d'exploitation en fait vous comprends
pas ce soir thomas mann toute nation ou
sans conscience universelle est temps
que tu sais qu'elles ont fauté l'oxygène
qui sert en coupe à des peines a gagné
division pour contrer au pourquoi bête
sauvage en plein oubliés même s'ils
comptent echiré même si au pays au pape
vient jamais face aux inscrits aurait
gagné mais moi mais julien doré noir est
plus à ce mondial sans josiane
l'embroussaillement comme travail
patrick à effry pyramidale on joue une
place pour un apport nous retourner trop
longtemps aucun moment sa maman elie
blessants ou peuvent chanter aux pommes
nationaux célébrer épouse a bien honoré
aux appels passés n'ont pas
[Musique]
m
quoi
[Musique]
les agenaises claire corps frêle est
prise dans mon teint sens aussi réelle
que tam d'or crois moi j'en sors j'ai dû
tenir le combat et hardcore son garde du
corps même pas la moulinette du match de
non dits qui sait pourquoi on est
condamné à payer les pots cassés s'est
passé ou tissage me rhabiller qui vit
toile d'araignée mais cech sa réalité
commence à sentir le 4 et on n'est plus
figée d'antan où les gants nous sommes
figés à bout portant ou les baumes et
pose à tout bout de champ menacé fini
très limité ses choix rien ne blanchir à
la décennie noire notre survie et une
victoire 9 ans de mémoire quand on est
dans la merde tu veux buts et les cons
qui chie sur de l'avant dans que nos
frères se sont butés par des plans de
gaza a bâti mois en remontant de tati
toi et surtout ton sport santé
m
[Musique]
macquarie cook a dominé la minorité
domine à la matinale à nawa que celle à
ses locaux
[Musique]
m
parce que ma culture
les dieux marquent à jamais méchant
soyouz
oui
[Applaudissements]
ap
[Musique]
je
à
j'ai eu quand même beaucoup c'est tout
on y avait une troisième question mais
on vous épargne à faire ce qu'ils ont
50% à lever la main
il trompe les esprits beaucoup de
soldats soccer au tableau le gagnant au
banc bravo à bien alors écoutez si on
veut faire partie du comité des employés
gay
j'ai pas comme ça que vous le nommez
vous avez une voix lgbt d'accord q
qu'est-ce qu'on fait exactement noah qui
doit être l'ex tu sais moi on a une page
sur surio sur l'intranet corporatif puis
on a une adresse courriel voix point
lgbt qu at radio tirait canada.ca et
donc on peut nous rejoindre et tout le
monde est bienvenu
pas besoin de faire partie de la
diversité sexuelle pour nous rejoindre
le message est donc lancée autour de la
planète parce que vous savez que vous
êtes à l'antenne de radio canada est en
national c'est mal parti c'est parfait
oui à l'écouté
paloma vous saluer vos invités oui on a
ici pascal laby merci beaucoup pascal
olimpico mercy james françois vous en
prie diana gonzalez merci de
l'invitation
franck hanoh ce bassin est ce qu'on
devrait faire ci revenir l'an prochain
vous devriez être là-bas dire si on a
beaucoup progressé
en tout cas vous pouvez continuer à nous
écrire durant la saison durant l'année
puis à nous provoquer à nous le relancer
et je pense qu'on voudrait reprendre
l'expérience si on doit faire ça à tout
et année tous les mois même s'il le faut
comme vous le disiez oui très bien fait
des parties je vais vous dire que cette
émission spéciale de radio canada
international sur les plateformes
youtube facebook et puis sur you c'est
une idée originale de soliman mellali
rédacteur en chef de radio canada c'est
lui qui en a eu l'idée
bravo
et puis vers nas évidemment les
collègues ici autour de tables d'abord
je voudrais remercier millénaire
madeleine dupuis merci beaucoup
c'était une décision de dernière minute
de vous asseoir à côté du prince
et puis magnifique magnifique et puis
j'ai le cormier c'était votre dernière
prestation officielle avant l'abattoir
de tête
non ça fait ça finit bien une carrière
comme un nouveau sur ce si on mettrait
sa dent voix d'avancé
et puis je me dois merci beaucoup d'être
venus d'ottawa avec les pour nous donner
des nouvelles puis à préciser les
statistiques c'était important pour nous
et puis je me tourner vers fadi m merci
beaucoup d'être venu d'ukraine du crâne
et puis les 25 ans également merci
beaucoup merci merci chantal alléchante
à moi je vous appelle toujours chantage
pourquoi c'est très sympathique mais si
oui c'est vraiment sympathique
un nom de l'un ou l'autre alice ou
chantal merci de 50 ha de champs des
mots voilà la section française de
radio-canada est en national il ya cinq
sections à notre et à notre planète
notre émission pas encore mais en
général il y en a peut-être de notre
émission on évite beaucoup les collègues
je voulais vous dire qu'il ya eu toute
une équipe technique de radio canada qui
étaient avec nous aujourd'hui si
j'oublie des non c'est pas parce que
c'est parce qu'on en oublie même envoyé
un courriel d'accord très bien alors
voici nicolas bolduc il est responsable
de la mise en ondes télé joël vous
applaudissent y est parce que sinon un
radhia merci beaucoup du coc la ville
m'a envoyé des courriels caméraman eric
carbonneau lots d'anigo cela se
manifeste pas beaucoup c'est plutôt
derrière la caméra
notre chef technicien web maxime l'abri
la transmission était la responsabilité
de martin celestino et le directeur
technique nouvelles de radio-canada qui
était responsable de tout ça c'était
stéphane en tilt je vais relancer
également luc simard et ekram ben sassi
du service de la diversité relation
citoyenne qui nous ont beaucoup aidé à
leur invitation qu'on a eu l'idée de
cette initiative
voilà au panneau ma j'ai failli oublier
non mais ça m'aurait fait beaucoup de
peine
non merci à vous parce que
vous maniez de choses de francs la co
animation et la descente de l'escalier à
la vitesse de la lumière
merci alors si j'ai oublié quelqu'un en
sélectionnant ya une chance de lever la
main pier dutil jour utiles comme la
honte merci beaucoup et puis sur le web
on votre vendredi de la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]